موقف الولايات المتحده الامريكيه يتغير
ببطء باتجاه الحزم على ما يبدو ويلوح بهذه
التحذيرات للروس هذه الملعب هناك على ما
يبدو وعيون امريكي تام بان دولا مثل روسيا
والصين تحوم حول النيجر وغرب افريقيا هل
تجد هذه التحذيرات كما استمعنا الان اذنا
صغيرا في موسكو لا توجد اي بوادر على
الاقل في هذه المرحله على ان شركه فاجنر
العسكريه الروسيه
تلعب دور من الادوار التي انيطت لها في
الدول الافريقيه اخرى في الفتره السابقه
لعده اعتبارات لاعلى ابرزها الاحداث التي
حامت حول فاجنر والتي تمثلت في محاوله
التمرد الاخيره تركيز هذه المجموعه
العسكريه في الوقت الراهن على تثبيت
قواعدها في بيلاروسيا الوضع في النيجر في
هذه الفتره الراهنه ما زالت غير واضحه
المعالم الى اي حد
في التقرب من اولئك الزعماء في افريقيا
مساله التقارب او احداث تقارب تطمح له
روسيا على الاقل في هذه المرحله
يبدو ان له وجهان الوجه الاول يتمثل في ان
روسيا ترى من جهه بانها نجحت حتى الان في
هذه المرحله وفق المتطلبات ووفقا
الاستراتيجيه التي اعتمدتها في عدد من
الدول على انها حققت
مكانه تخطط له وجه اخر في الحقيقه
مليء بالتحديات التي ما زالت تواجهها
روسيا في القاره السمراء هناك اهتمام بدور
روسي لربما من خلال ذلك النموذج التي
تحاول روسيا ان تبرزه في القاره السمراء
والذي يعد مخالف للنموذج الغربي هذا
النموذج على ما يبدو يعتمد على مقاربه
امنيه بالدرجه الاولى تتمثل في مساعده
بعض الدول في التدريب قواتها اضافه الى
تقديم المعونات عسكريه اي زعيم افريقي
يعتقد ان روسيا وبوتين تحديدا يحمل اي قدر
من التقدير والاحترام لاي دوله افريقيه هو
مخطي روسيا لا تتحرك كدوله لها تفكير
استراتيجي بل تتحرك كنظام
هو فئه قليله متمثله في بوتين وبعض من
اصدقائه
نواجه كارثه في النيجر لانه ليس هناك اي
سبب لهذه المحاوله الانقلابيه هناك خطر
حدوث نتائج وخيمه اذا لم يتم العثور على
حل المعقول وسلمي كانت المؤسسات تعمل بشكل
جيد وطبيعي وكان الحوار السياسي مع من
يعرضون النظام يسر بشكل جيد لقد كان
الامريكيون واضحين وحازمين نشروا البيانات
التي يمكن الاطلاع عليها على موقع
الخارجيه كما تحدث الوزير بلينكن مع رئيس
بازون وقال له ان الولايات المتحده تدعم
بشكل كامل حكومته من الواضح ان موقف
الامريكي ارجع سيكون قريب جدا مع موقف
الايكروز مجموعه دول
الغربي افريقيا
[موسيقى]
لا لا اعتقد ان اي شخص في الحكومه
الامريكيه اذا تطلع الى القيام بالدخول في
عمل عسكري في النيجر لا زال لدينا
1100 جندي امريكي هناك يقومون بتدريب
العسكر النيجيريا وحسب علمهم باقون في
مكانهم على امل ان عمليه التتريب ستستانف
بعد وقت معين الهدف هو في الواقع والامل
معقود على الجانب الدبلوماسي لاعاده حكم
القانون والحكومه المدنيه لا اعتقد ان
هنالك اي رغبه في الوقت الراهن من قبل
الاداره الامريكيه باستخدام اي شكل من
اشكال القوه العسكريه ولا اعتقد ان الحدود
استنفذت ارى ان هنالك
فرصه للعمل الدبلوماسي مجموعه الاقواس
اجتمعت من قبل ايام على مستوى الرؤساء
واصدرت بيانا قويا انترت فيه الانقلابيون
على انهم لابد من استعاده
باستخدام المقاطعات الاقتصاديه نيجيريا
تحديدا لها علاقات قويه مع النيجر وحوالي
70% من امدادات الطاقه في النيجر تاتي من
نيجيريا ماذا تقرا في تصريحات رئيس
الاكواس يبدو لي حديث على مستوى الرؤساء
لابد ان يكون حديثا جدا لا اعتقد ان
الرئيس النيجيري ولا مجموعه تتحدث ببساطه
حينما تقول انها على استعداد لاستخدام
العمل العسكري اذا تطلب الامر في تقديري
ربما ياتي هذا الوقت ولم يعد اذا لم يعد
هنالك خيار للعمل الدبلوماسي والمقاطعات
الاقتصاديه والحوار لاستعاده النظام
الدستوري في النيجر ربما تستخدم قوات
الاكواس جزء من قواتها المشتركه في محاوله
استعاده النظام الديمقراطي هل
تعطونا اي قيمه سياسيه ودبلوماسيه
لتصريحات قويه من اكوس اعتقد نعم فهناك
جزء من الدبلوماسيه في هذا الموضوع حاليا
لا يمكن لاي شخص ان يستبعد العمل العسكري
وهو الخطوه الاقل رغبه لدى الجميع ولكن
اعتقد ان الدول الديمقراطيه بانه لابد من
تركيز الاثان الانقلابيين في النيجر
ليدركوا بانهم قد اتخذوا خطوه غير مقبوله
ولذلك فربما هناك احتمال عمل عسكري ضدهم
هذا يعتبر امر حساس جدا رغم انه بالتاكيد
لن يكون الخطوه الاولى
[موسيقى]
الخطر في موقف الاكواس هو انه وضع جدول
زمن فتره محدده
لارسال قوات عسكريه الى النيجر هذا الجدول
الزمني سوف نصله قريبا وليس هناك بصراحه
اي مؤشر بان القوات من الاكواس ستصل الى
النيجر في ذلك الوقت وهذا طبعا يؤثر
ويقللوا من موقف الايكو اس الوضع فعلا
اكثر تعقيدا الان ولم نصل حتى الى موضوع
ما يمكن تذكر الدول الاخرى تفعل الدول
الاخرى عدد الولايات المتحده مثل ما يمكن
اقوم بفرنسا او يكون تقوم به روسيا وهل
لنا للصين اي مصلحه في كل هذا وهذه كلها
اسئله مفتوحه
اوراق الضغط او الاوراق المقنعه لنقل
للمفوضين اعتقد ان الوقت مبكر للحديث عن
ان كل الاوراق الضغطه المتاحه للاداره
الامريكيه
وزير الخارجيه الامريكيه قد نفذت النجم من
البلدان الفقيره جدا حتى ابن معايير
الافريقيه نعم اكيد اقتصاد اقتصاد مترنح
يعتمد اعتماد كلي على المساعدات في تقديري
استخدام العقوبات الاقتصاديه وقفه
للمساعدات العقوبات الدبلوماسيه المتعلقه
بربما عقوبات مباشره على المسؤولين بمنعهم
من الحصول على تاشيرات هل تعتقدون ان
النيجر ربما تعتمد على الروس مستقبلا كلا
لا ارى ان روسيا لديها هذه القدره روسيا
تلعب دورا واحده رئيسيا في افريقيا اليوم
وهو تزويدها بالاسلحه فهي اكبر مزود
بالاسلحه لكل القاره الافريقيه وقد تستمر
بدعم هذا الدور وتكسب اموالا كبيره من ذلك
روسيا تتعامل تجاريه مع افريقيا بنفس
المستوى اليوم كما كان اثناء القمه
الافريقيه الروسيه في في 2019